NEW YORK CITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: LIVE FROM NEW YORK,
IT'S MONDAY NIGHT.
TUCKER, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
GREAT SHOW AS USUAL.
BUCKLE UP, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
MAJOR WIN FOR THE UNITED STATES,
THE TOUGH NEGOTIATION WITH
MEXICO, OH, THEY PAID OFF A
MASSIVE BIG WAY.
THE PRESIDENT WINS, MEXICO
AGREED TO STAY ON THE FLOW OF
MIGRATION WITH NEW BORDER
POLICIES AND 6,000
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, YEAH, HE
HAD MEXICO BUCKLE TO THEIR
KNEES.
WITHOUT THE HELP OF ANY
REPUBLICANS IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
OH, WHAT HAPPENS?
WE WILL HAVE A TRADE WAR.
ALL RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT WON AND
STOOD STRONG.
AND WE ARE BETTER OFF FOR IT.
WE WILL HAVE MORE IN THE MOMENT.
BUT WE START TONIGHT BREAKING
JUST MINUTES AGO, BIG NEWS FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OF THE UNITED STATES.
IN A LETTER OBTAINED BY
FOX NEWS, THE ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL STEPHEN BOYD
EXPLAINS THAT THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA
WHICH POINT OH MAC HUNT IS BROAD
IN SCOPE GO UP AND WILL COVER
ACTIVITIES OF U.S. AND SERVICES
AS WELL AS NONGOVERNMENTAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT CONFIRMATION
THAT THE INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS HAS NOT AND HAS
NEVER BEEN IN VAIN.
FACTS, TRUTH, JUSTICE.
AS WE HAVE TOLD YOU, ABOUT TO
CASCADE DOWN ON ALL OF THESE
DEEP STATE BAD ACTORS.
THOSE THAT ABUSE POWER.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE IN THE
COURSE OF THE HOUR AND MORE IN A
MOMENT.
BUT WILL BE FOCUSED ON HOLDING
THE GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE ON
CAPITOL HILL, WELL, YOU HAVE
JERRY NADLER CIRCUS AND CLOWN
SHOW IN FULL GEAR.
AND TODAY THE DEMOCRATIC
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, LITERALLY JUMPED THE
SHARK.
INSTEAD OF PASSING LAWS OR
PERFORMING RESPONSIBLE
OVERSIGHT, NADLER INSTEAD, WELL,
HE INVITED O'FALLON, THE KNOWN
PERJURER, LIAR, JOHN DEAN TO
TESTIFY.
YES, THE JOHN DEAN, THE FILL AND
TURN PARTISAN HACK, FAKE NEW CNN
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
HE WAS A BIG STAR WITNESS TODAY.
BUT YOU MIGHT REMEMBER JOHN DEAN
WAS ONCE THE WHITE HOUSE CANCEL
UNDER RICHARD NIXON WHERE HE WAS
KNOWN AS THE MASTER MANIPULATOR
OF THE WATERGATE COVER-UP.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF LYING A
WHOPPING 19 TIMES TO FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS.
I THINK THAT HE FORGOT THAT
THERE WERE TAPES.
AND OF COURSE OBSTRUCTING
JUSTICE.
JOHN DEAN IS A CONVICTED FELON,
HE WAS DISBARRED MANY TIMES AGO
FOR "BEING UNETHICAL,
UNPROFESSIONAL, AND UNWARRANTED
CONDUCT."
DISBARRED TOO, PERFECT GUY FOR
FAKE NEWS CNN.
TRASHING DONALD TRUMP DAILY FOR
THE MAINSTREAM LYING MEDIA MOB.
AND THE CD TRACK RECORD WITH
LYING, HE FITS RIGHT IN THERE.
NATURALLY OF COURSE,
JERRY NADLER WAS HAPPY TO GIVE
THE KNOWN LIAR, CONVICTED FELON
ANOTHER PLATFORM.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CIRCUS.
>> THE LAST TIME I APPEARED
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE WAS
JULY 11, 1974.
DURING THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
OF RICHARD NIXON.
IN MANY WAYS, THE MUELLER REPORT
IS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP WHAT THE
SO-CALLED WATERGATE ROAD MAP
OFFICIALLY TIED OVER THE GRAND
JURY REPORT AND RECOMMENDATION
CONCERNING TRANSMISSION OF
EVIDENCE TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
WAS TO PRESIDENT RICHARD NIXON.
STATING IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY, SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER HAS PROVIDED THIS
COMMITTEE WITH A ROAD MAP.
>> Sean: CONVICTED FELON KNOWN
LIAR, COMPARING A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT TO RICHARD NIXON.
THIS IS HOW HE NOW MAKES A
LIVING.
IT IS NOTHING NEW FOR THE
DISGRACE CNN FAKE NEWS
MOUTHPIECE.
IN FACT, A FEW YEARS AGO DEAN
WROTE A BOOK CALLING FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT OF OH,
GEORGE W. BUSH.
IN THAT BOOK WAS ENTITLED "WORSE
THAN WATERGATE."
IT IS A LINE HE USES OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND IS DOING THE SAME
THING.
DEAN WAS GETTING PAID BY CNN TO
TRASH DONALD TRUMP, WELL, HE WAS
DOING THE EXACT SAME THING TO A
FORMER PRESIDENT BUSH.
HE HAS A BROKEN RECORD, PLAY THE
LOOP.
>> I HAVE REALLY NEVER SEEN AS
SECRET A PRESIDENCY AS WE NOW
HAVE PLAYED >> I THINK THAT THEY
FOUND AN OLD PLAYBOOK DOWN IN
THE BASEMENT THAT BELONG TO
RICHARD NIXON AND THEY SAID THAT
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WORKS.
BE SPECIFIC WITH ME, WHAT IS
WORSE THAN WATERGATE?
>> IF THERE IS ANYTHING TO
REALLY HIT THE BOTTOM LINE, IT
IS TAKING A NATION TO WAR ANY
TIME WHEN THEY MIGHT NOT --
MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD TO GO TO WAR.
I WOULD NOT USE THE TITLE "WORSE
THAN WATERGATE" IF I DID NOT
TRULY BELIEVE WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN THE PRESIDENCY IS FAR WORSE
THAN ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED IN I
THAN ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED IN N
THE NIXON PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: WORSE THAN WATERGATE,
WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
HE GETS PAID FOR REGURGITATING
THE SAME STUPID LINE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AS A CONVICTED FELON
AND A KNOWN LIAR.
AND JOHN DEAN HAS BEEN USED AS A
PROP BY THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA MOB
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR
YEARS.
TODAY'S HEARING WAS A SHAM, A
CIRCUS.
A DEMOCRATIC PROPAGANDA, PAID
FOR BY YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
EARLIER CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ
HAD THIS TO SAY TED NADLER STAR
WITNESS.
PRETTY BIG TAPE TAKE DOWN, LET'S
LOOK.
>> DO YOU HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
FALSITY OF A SINGLE MATERIAL
FACT IN THE MUELLER REPORT?
>> I THINK THE FIRST THING I
SAID WAS I AM NOT HERE IS A FACT
WITNESS.
>> YOU ACCUSE PRESIDENTS OF
ACTING LIKE RICHARD NIXON AND
YOU MAKE MONEY.
>> NOT ALL PRESIDENTS.
>> HERE WE SIT WITH THE GHOST OF
CHRISTMAS PAST, BECAUSE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE HAS
GONE TO THE SPEAKER THE HOUSE
AND SOUGHT PERMISSION TO OPEN AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
AND SHE HAS SAID NO.
YOU ARE FUNCTIONALLY HERE AS A
PROP, BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BECAUSE 70% OF DEMOCRATS WANT
SOMETHING THAT 60% OF AMERICANS
DON'T.
>> Sean: CHECKMATE, AND
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ WAS ONE OF
MANY REPUBLICANS WHO CALLED OUT
DEAN AND HIS SELF-SERVING
ABUSIVELY BIASED TESTIMONY.
IT DID I MENTION THAT HE WAS A
FELON?
ANY OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE CORRUPT COBOL OF PAGE,
McCABE, COMEY AND OTHERS, I
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE THE
GODFATHER HERE.
>> NOW WE HAVE JOHN DEAN, 45
YEARS AGO WENT TO PLEADING
GUILTY OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, NOW COMING INTO
ENLIGHTENED THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE WHEN WE COULD BE GOING
RIGHT TO THE START OF HOW THIS
WHOLE THING STARTED.
>> WE ARE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
YOUR CREDIBILITY AS A WITNESS.
YOU ARE A BIASED WITNESS AS
WELL.
HE SPENT THE LAST 45 YEARS
TRYING TO REHABILITATE YOURSELF.
AND I DON'T BLAME YOU.
AND YOU HAVE WRITTEN NUMEROUS
BOOKS.
YOU HAVE CLAIMED MULTIPLE
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATIONS AS
BEING WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
>> NOW MR. DEAN, I HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH YOU HAVING AN
OPINION.
YOU PAY YOUR DEBT TO SOCIETY.
YOU HAVE MADE YOUR OPINION
CLEAR.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS DID YOU
KNOW THAT YOU SENT 970 TWEETS
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
ALL 970 TWEETS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP ARE
ANTI-DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: DID I MENTION THAT HE
WAS A LIAR, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AND A FELON?
AND HIS TESTIMONY SMACKS THE
DEMOCRATIC DESPERATION.
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER A
HOAX, NO COLLUSION, NO
CONSPIRACY, NO OBSTRUCTION
PRETTY IS NOT A FACT WITNESS.
AND RECOMMENDING NO CHARGES PAID
TO THE GENERAL, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
PRESENTED NO INDICTMENTS IN A
NOTHING TO DO WITH DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE POLICY OR ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE.
AS OH, EVEN MUELLER SAID.
COMPARE THAT TO THE INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL KEN STARR WHO WILL JOIN
US IN A MOMENT.
FOLLOWING HIS 1998 INVESTIGATION
INTO THEN-PRESIDENT
BILL CLINTON, KEN STARR DETAILED
11 SPECIFIC FILLINGS DONE IN
FELONIES WHERE HE COULD BE
IMPEACHED.
BUT LOST HIS LAW LICENSE AND WAS
BUT BACK THEN JERRY NADLER AND
HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS PUSHED
HARD.
THEY DID NOT WANT THE KEN STARR
REPORT RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC.
WOW, WHAT A DIFFERENT
JERRY NADLER HE WAS BACK IN THE
DAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE STAFF OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, PERHAPS THE CHAIRMAN
AND RANKING ARGUMENT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WILL HAVE TO GO
OVER THIS MATERIAL.
AT LEAST THE FOUR OR 500 PAGES
IN THE REPORT TO DETERMINE WHAT
IS FIT FOR A RELEASE, AND WHAT
IS DECENCY AND PROTECTING
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY RIGHTS.
MAYBE THIRD PARTIES THAT SHOULD
NOT BE RELEASED AT ALL.
>> Sean: SO IT IS NADLER'S
CIRCUS, NO SHAME, A POLITICAL
HACK MISSING YOUR MONEY.
AND WHAT HAS TO BE ONE --
BECOMING ONE OF THE MOST EPIC
FLIP-FLOPS IN AMERICAN POLITICAL
HISTORY.
ONLY A FEW WEEKS AGO, NOW THEY
ARE ACTUALLY THREATENING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WITH
ATTEMPT BY CONGRESS.
NOT FOR DECLASSIFYING, JUST TWO
FULL AND PARTIAL LINES OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
EVERYTHING WAS RELEASED ON
OBSTRUCTION, THE SECTION THAT
WAS REDACTED WAS BECAUSE THE LAW
DEMANDS IT.
IT HAD GRAND JURY MATERIAL.
HE WAS ASKING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO COMMIT A
CRIME AND REVEAL GRAND JURY
MATERIAL.
HE LITERALLY WANTED AMERICA'S
TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BREAK THE
LAW OR HOLD HIM IN CONTEMPT.
AT THIS FROM A GUY WHO
DESPERATELY TRIED TO KEEP THE
STARR REPORT HIDDEN FROM YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT IS HIS
HYPOCRISY ON STEROIDS AND HUMAN
GROWTH HOMEROOM.
-- HORMONE.
I WONDER HOW LONG THIS IS GOING
TO LAST, BUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE DONE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN HIS POLITICAL
CIRCUS WHICH IS THE RIGHT
DECISION.
FOR YEARS THE WHITE HOUSE
COOPERATED FULLY WITH MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE HAD THE FBI 9-MONTH
INVESTIGATION.
NO COLLUSION.
HOUSE UNTIL INVESTIGATION, NO
COLLUSION.
BIPARTISAN PROBE IN THE SENATE,
NO COLLUSION.
MUELLER'S 22 MONTH WITCH HUNT.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
AND   AN END DURING THE YEAR LON
AND   AN END DURING THE YEAR LOG
PROCESS, NOT ONE TIME, NOT A
SINGLE MOMENT OF THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE EVER EXERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
NOT ONCE.
THE PRESIDENT ENCOURAGED EVERY
PERSON IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION TO PARTICIPATE
FULLY, AND THEY DID.
THEY HANDED OVER 1.5 MILLION
DOCUMENTS TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
AND THE WHITE HOUSE ATTORNEY
EVEN DON MCGANN WAS INTERVIEWED
BY A MUELLER FOR 30 HOURS WHICH
TO ME IS INSANITY.
THE PRESIDENT ANSWERED MUELLER'S
QUESTIONS HIMSELF.
NOW IT IS ALL OVER, NO
COLLUSION, AND THE PRESIDENT
WILL NOT ALLOW DEMOCRATS TO
LITERALLY DRAG AMERICANS THROUGH
THIS PROCESS YET AGAIN FOR WHAT
WOULD BE A FIFTH INVESTIGATION.
AND THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
NOW RIGHTLY SAYING ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
EXERTING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE PIT
HOUSE DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RELITIGATE THE RUSSIA PROBE FOR
A FIFTH TIME.
IT IS NO ABUSE OF POWER, AND THE
NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT, MORE
IMPORTANTLY, PEOPLE THAT WERE
FOR THE PRESIDENT TRYING TO
SERVE THEIR COUNTRY SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO SHELL OUT TENS AND TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL
FEES ANSWERING THE SAME
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AND LITERALLY SIT FOR A PERJURY
TRAP.
WITNESSES AND DOCUMENTS, FORGET
IT.
IT IS DONE.
THAT WILL NOT BE MADE AVAILABLE.
THIS IS THE RIGHT DECISION FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
THE VAST POWERS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NEVER BE USED
TWO OPPRESSED AMERICANS.
AND HARASS A SITTING PRESIDENT,
AND COST THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
WHAT IS NOW A FIFTH
INVESTIGATION INTO THE SAME
TOPIC.
AND BY THE WAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT THE FIRST PRESIDENT TO
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
ALTHOUGH HE DID NOT DO IT WITH
MUELLER.
FORMER PRESIDENT CLINTON DID IT
A WHOPPING 14 TIMES.
MEANWHILE, OBAMA SUCCESSFULLY
UTILIZED EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
BLOCKING THE REQUEST OF DOCUMENT
SURROUNDING, REMEMBER FAST AND
FURIOUS, THE GUNRUNNING SCANDAL.
AN AMERICAN DIED AS A RESULT OF
THAT STUPID POLICY.
AND THE FAST AND FURIOUS
PROGRAM.
OBAMA ALSO TRIED TO WITHHOLD
DOCUMENT SURROUNDING THE FAILED
SOLYNDRA PROJECT, AND BENGHAZI
IN THE ATTACK THERE.
HE TRIED, BUT HE TURNED THEM
OVER.
HE WAS FORCED TO.
I HAVE SOME ADVICE FOR NADLER,
SCHIFF AND ALL OF THE DEMOCRATS
ABUSING THEIR POWER AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMART.
THEY WILL NOT SUPPORT YOUR
IMPEACHMENT.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY ARE SICK
AND TIRED OF YOUR LIVES, YOUR
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND OR PHONY
RUSSIA HOAX.
IF YOU CONTINUE DOWN THIS ROAD,